c'est le genre de surprise que de
nombreux automobilistes redoute et cette
fois les forces de l'ordre sont réunis
avec gendarmes d'un côté et policiers de
l'autre les excès de vitesse se
succèdent
du moins jusqu'à ce que l'embouteillage
n'envahisse la rocade 110 kilomètres à
l'heure pour cette moto c'est entre
autres ce que le combattre le préfet en
rendant les sanctions deux fois plus
sévères pour les contrevenants
le nombre d'accidents corporels a
augmenté de 25 % en 2017
il faut réagir je le dis très clairement
on a décidé d'augmenter les barèmes
parce qu'il faut cogner pour changer les
comportements des automobilistes trop
d'excès de vitesse trop d'alcoolémie sur
la route
donc il nous faut réagir et faire
comprendre aux automobilistes que ces
mesures là elles sont là pour les
protéger en 2017
trente personnes ont perdu la vie sur
nos routes et dans un cas sur deux la
consommation d'alcool ou de stupéfiants
a été avérée d'où ce nouveau barème
spécifique à la martinique qui
pourraient être appliquées a déjà
nécessité une organisation particulière
du parquet parallèlement à cette
harmonisation des barèmes il ya eu
également un renforcement plus que
significatif s'agisse en l'occurrence
des équipes dédiées au sein du parquet à
la répression de ce type de comportement
puisque ce sont pas moins de six
nouveaux délégués du procureur qui ont
été recrutés tout au long de cette année
2010 est de sorte qu'aujourd'hui ce sont
pas moins de huit délégués du procureur
qui agissent dans ce domaine là
six mois de suspension du permis pour
plus de 0.80 mg d'alcool par litre de
sang au lieu de tout pas moi aujourd'hui
des mesures drastiques accueillie
différemment selon les automobilistes
j'imagine que ça va servir à quelque
chose à quoi je ne sais pas moi je pense
que ça va changer parce que les gens
comme on dit aussi ils ont envie de
consommer et kodjo après ils vont le
faire d'où ils peuvent mettre même dix
mille euros damende ça va changer
il ya des gens qui voient et puis sa
femme se tiennent du célé donc le plus
souvent ce sont les motards qui sont ils
sont impliqués d'honneur à l'ordre que
c'est une bonne chose
en 2010 7 865 rétention administrative
de permis avaient été prononcés en
martinique
pour le seul mois de décembre cent
soixante dix huit d'entre elles avaient
été liés à l'alcool